these people on the island of Guam are
preparing for typhoon Mawa the storm is
barreling towards the island with strong
winds and rain we usually pack
everything up
for most of our stuff inside the garage
and just secure everything even
especially the windows
people are stocking up on essential
supplies
the typhoon could be the biggest to hit
Guam in two decades the governor has
told people to remain calm my greatest
concern and worry is your safety all
residents in low-lying flood prone and
coastal areas are ordered to evacuate
and seek shelter in private residences
or designated government shelters in
higher elevation
more than 170 000 people live on the
island in the North Pacific Ocean
authorities fear the storm may cause
devastating damage excess Winds of 130
miles per hour and gusting pushing to
150 or so
so right now we've been seeing the
conditions change uh typhoon award
continues to intensify no surprise
all the ingredients were there to
support an intensifying system
at the islands in the region have been
placed under a typhoon warning but the
people of Guam face an anxious weight
Al Jazeera